so i mentioned this yesterday in passing
but i want to talk about it a little bit
more because it is really
um a fascinating story uh we are now
learning something that i knew and if
you watch this show you also knew about
the fundraising that was done in the
aftermath of the 2020 election by the
trump campaign and the republican party
supposedly to fight for the true results
and to fund audits and to fund recounts
and all these different things we all
knew it was a scam and the last i
checked in with you about it about 70 or
75 million dollars had been donated by
just random people who many of whom
don't really have the money to be
donating although some millionaires
donated as well to donald trump
and we knew that it was a scam if you
looked at the fine print you actually
could see that in some cases 50 cents on
every dollar or even more
were earmarked to pay off trump campaign
debt but it's way worse than that one of
the things we learned from the committee
hearings the january 6 trump riot
committee hearing on monday was that the
entire 250 million dollar official trump
election integrity fund or whatever they
called it it was a complete and total
grift scam used in many cases to pay
outrageous speaking fees and salaries to
trump's friends and family that's the
bottom line and i know it's sort of like
well of course i mean look at what
happened with trump university look at
all the different scams that donald
trump has run of course it was a scam
but it wasn't obvious to the people who
needed to hear it the most the trumpist
so let's dig into that a little bit more
zoe lofgren congresswoman zoe lofgren a
democrat who's on the january 6
committee she was interviewed by jake
tapper and they talked about this and
they specifically talk about donald
trump jr's then girlfriend i believe now
fiance kimberly gilfoyle check this out
you showed
people deceived talking about why they
were there on january 6. well people
were conned by the former president
they were conned into believing that the
election had been stolen
and that they should go to the capitol
as the president asked them to they were
conned out i think the average donation
from those email uh false email requests
was something like 17
these were people who weren't rich
people right they were
conned by the president it was a big lie
and it was also a big ripoff and you say
you were just asked i think by manu raju
if the committee has found evidence that
trump and his family quote personally
benefited personally benefited from
donations and you said
yes that's a serious allegation do you
have more details is that a crime
i don't know
you know we're a legislative committee
so that's that's for somebody else to
decide uh but for example we know that
um
guilfoyle was paid uh for the
introduction she gave at the speech i
mean on january 6 you received
compensation for that
but is that a is that a crime i'm not
saying it's a crime but i think it's a
grift it's a grift because you're you're
telling trump people trump supporters
out there in the hinterlands keep give
us money to to
uh to
to go to court to defend this election
when in fact and then instead kim
guilfoyle who is donald trump jr's
fiance gets paid money for sixty sixty
thousand dollars for two two and a half
minutes um you had uh money going to
uh mark meadows foundation and to
another foundation he hired the trump
supporters who'd lost their jobs so it
wasn't what he said to his donors this
is to defend the election it was an
entirely different purpose okay so you
get the point
what a teacher makes in a year hopefully
after having years of experience in
education many teachers don't make this
okay
kimberly guilfoyle
the fiance of donald trump jr makes for
a two and a half minute speech on the
day january 6 paid for by paid for by
the people who mostly don't make
60 000
a year she gets it for two and a half
minutes imagine
giving
in some cases your social security check
to a billionaire
supposedly to fund lawyers who are
trying to sort out the election for us
and then it actually goes four hundred
dollars a second to his son's future
wife
okay and what's amazing is how they are
such transparent grifters but people
fall for it anyway now i know that some
of you say
screw
screw and yeah to some degree okay i
mean they they the fool and their money
are soon parted if you believe after
trump did all the other scams uh we're
gonna build a wall that mexico is gonna
pay for but they some of them fell for
that obviously it wasn't gonna happen
we're going to replace obamacare with
something beautiful never even got a
proposal all the if they still fall for
it then they deserve it sure that's fine
and it's less about the individual but
it is a reminder that these are not
people the entire political constituency
of trump are people he mostly hates
trump as a rich new york city guy has
spent most of his life trying to stay
isolated and insulated from the very
people who he cons out of money and once
they're no longer useful trump uh throws
them out like uh like his dirty diapers
for lack of a better term um
and the criminality question is a
different one is it is it arguably
fraudulent yes it's arguably fraudulent
but like zoe lofgren says they are a
legislative committee they are not uh
law enforcement and that's going to have
to be looked at aaron rupar had a really
really good piece about this actually um
in which he
outlines
some of the different um
payments that were made and we're going
to link to that and you can check that
out but absolutely outrageous stuff one
of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video